(upbeat music)
- [Gary] Alright, The
GaryVee Audio Experience
brings you After the App
and this is the important show
because these two
gentlemen are the generals,
they are the infrastructure,
the backbone,
the captains of
Planet of the Apps.
Ben Silverman, Howard Owens,
I am humbled to
have you on the podcast.
For the couple of
people in the Vayner Nation
that don't know
who you gentlemen are,
Howard, we're gonna start with
you and your beautiful face.
Tell everybody who you are
and a little bit
about your career.
- [Howard] I'm Howard Owens,
great to see you, GaryVee.
Great to talk to
Vayner Nation, love you guys.
Big fans, first time,
first time caller,
longtime listener.
- [Gary] You're not calling,
you're actually a guest.
- I know but I'm just
referring to talk radio.
- [Gary] Can you
turn off your phone, dick?
- Remember what that used to be?
- [Gary] Jesus Christ,
you're ruining the show.
We're eight second into the--
- I turned my ringer off.
- [Gary] Alright, Ben,
Ben Silverman.
Let's, Howard, you
regroup over there.
- After I birthed Howard.
- [Gary] Yes, Ben, Ben.
We're gonna go with you
while Howard
drinks a little water here
and tries to reset himself.
- Tell the Vayner Nation
who you are.
You have an amazing career.
I mean if people go
into this Google hole
they'll be there for five days.
For such a young man,
you've had such
a prolific career
in the Hollywood landscape
and so tell everybody who
you are on Planet of the Apps
and a little bit
about your career.
- EP, I am executive
producer of Planet of the Apps
with my partner over here,
Howard T. Owens III,
the son of a Connecticut
legislature and judge.
So I'll help do
Howard's job here.
- Thank you.
- Man of the
nation from Bridgeport
and not the good part of town.
We all know
Bridgeport's got two sides.
- [Gary] Other
side of the tracks.
- Other side of the tracks.
Self-made man but have
been a serial entrepreneur
and executive in
the entertainment world,
creating TV shows,
producing TV shows,
traveling the world,
looking for great ideas,
things like Jane the Virgin,
Ugly Betty, The Office,
that I EP-ed,
executive produced,
and then many other shows.
Co-created Biggest Loser with
Howard and some colleagues.
Nashville Star,
Date My Mom, The Restaurant.
Tons of different genres of TV.
Had the great privilege
of rehiring Donald Trump
to be on the
Celebrity Apprentice
when I was chairman of
NBC and Universal Media
and have been
enjoying making content forever
and love Planet of the Apps.
It just feels like
a game-changing show.
I had a show a long
time ago called Fashion Star.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Where we had Saks
Fifth Avenue, H&amp;M, and Macy's
as my judges on the show
but basically investing their
dough to buy product live.
Think a little bit
Project Runway meets HSN almost.
And that was kinda
something that was in my head
when Howard approached
me about Planet of the Apps
and that he was
thinking about the app space
and we collaborated.
- [Gary] It's interesting
about that show.
I think I got to tell you
this while we were filming.
That show more than any
show as me living my life,
blew my mind when I knew
that there was business
dynamics to the content.
Jessica Simpson, right?
- Exactly.
- [Gary] I remember this.
- Nicole Richie, John Varvatos.
- [Gary] Yep,
I remember this clearly.
I was like, holy shit.
Yep, it was the apec.
What was that?
2004, '05, '06, '07?
Where was that?
- [Ben] Yes, '07, '08.
- Yeah, I just
remember it was like,
reality was really happening
and I just remember thinking
that was such a big business
if it was a
humongously hit show.
Obviously you've
had a lot of hits.
That show didn't go crazy
the way I thought
it was going to.
Probably not the
way you guys thought
it was going to as well.
But the business
model was bonkers.
- [Ben] Bonkers and with apps,
we thought what was incredible
is you could,
that night download.
- Yep.
- [Ben] You can
actually access--
- [Howard] Right, within
the content ecosystem--
- Oh, you're back Howard,
you're back now?
- [Howard] And buy the app
or get the app or
experience the app
and I think Ben's,
what Ben did with
Fashion Star and prior to that
what we did with Biggest Loser
which was offer
weight loss programs
and diets to the
audience who were fans of Loser.
Ben took it to the next
level then with Fashion Star
and what we saw
with Planet of the Apps
was that the whole
and in doing with Apple
is the whole ecosystem
of consumption of media,
following your own apps,
becoming part of the show
and being able to experience
and purchase or download
and that whole 360
has never existed before.
- [Ben] When we
were working on this
and I think we talked to you
GaryVee about this early on.
Is this, if Who Wants
to Be a Millionaire
democratized the
game show, fastest finger.
You could literally
play the game from home
and be on the show.
What people forget
is during that
initial cycle of Millionaire
which aired on ABC, aired
initially five days in a row,
then five days in a row.
- [Gary] I remember.
- Aired for 10.
- [Gary] It was crazy.
- 10 nights in a row
and we had the privilege of
putting that show together
and bringing it over to America.
- [Gary] Regis dominated.
- Dominated, he
was our first choice.
- [Gary] Dom,
wasn't he the second choice?
Somebody, one of you
told me a good story.
- He wasn't the second choice
but we had
thought about Donahue.
- [Gary] Yes, I love that
'cause I wanna be Donahue.
I think I'm gonna bring
Donahue back in GaryVee form.
I'm doing daytime TV I think
and I want people to call me.
"Ingrid in Iowa,
what do you say?"
Like I've been
dreaming about this.
- [Ben] By the way,
you were manifesting
all your other dreams.
Why won't you be
the next Donahue?
- And then I'm gonna
win seven Super Bowls
as the owner of
the New York Jets,
and then I'll be ready to go.
- [Ben] I think the
latter's a lot tougher for you.
(Gary laughs)
I think I might,
I'm more on
the Bitcoin and the--
- I get it.
- [Howard] I was
thinking more Dinah Shore
when I see GaryVee.
- What's that Howard?
- [Ben] Michael Douglas.
- [Howard] Michael Douglas,
yeah.
- [Ben] He's got it.
But so if Millionaire
democratized the game show--
- Yes.
- [Ben] one of
those early episodes
if you saw a guy whose
partner was in the audience.
This was the first time
you had a gay contestant.
- Yes.
- [Ben] And it just happened
'cause the guy was smart
and he won the fastest finger
and got his way onto the show.
He wasn't cast
in the normal way.
Then you looked
at what Idol did.
You voted with your phone.
- Yes.
- [Ben] You made the choice.
It actually
started at Big Brother.
There was a whole lawsuit.
- Yes, I remember.
- [Ben] But Big Brother
did that telephony first.
That was the name.
- Yeah, I remember.
- [Ben] The name for around,
using your phone to vote,
and around everything
with the phone at that time.
Now apps is one step further
where you're
literally voting with your click
and your desire to--
- Yeah and your download.
- [Ben] Download this app
and participate in that way
and then obviously
the show's emotional heart
is these extraordinary
American dreams,
these amazing men and
women from all over the place
which I loved as
well about the show
'cause it's
democratized entrepreneurship.
Technology has enabled people
like you, Gary Vaynerchuk,
to be a King.
- Yeah.
- [Ben] And that's a lot harder
than when you would have started
trying to become
and compete 25--
- [Howard] We
were talking last night
about the casting process.
I was talking
to Nikki last night
and we were talking
about casting and finding apps
and how we went and did it
and people are
and you yourself said
people have reached out to
you since your show's come on
and you're like "Oh my god,
"they wanna have
their app on the show.
"It's a great experience."
Part of the idea behind the show
is not different
from say Nashville Star
where the first season
we found Miranda Lambert.
- Yep.
- [Howard] Who was a
18-year-old singer-songwriter,
guitar player, who
Sony Music told us,
you'll never really find anyone.
This is for posterity.
It'll be good for
marketing for the brand.
We find
Miranda Lambert in this show,
one of the things that
we think is cool and helpful
is to allow the glass ceiling
of Silicon Valley
to be shattered.
- [Howard] Is allow
anyone with an idea and the
kind of perseverance to
come and wait in line and
make their video,
and pitch their wares.
But as you know Gary, and
Aaron here still with us,
we go through an extremely
rigid vetting process where
we really want to make sure
people have what it takes,
but the fact
that anyone can do it.
We don't really
know who you are,
we don't check your CV
before you come on the show,
is a great
opportunity for people.
- Well, what's even
greater is that's the micro of
the macro, which is this
show is bringing awareness to
that world, but there's
millions of people that
will never be on this show
that are just doing a direct to
consumer at scale, you guys
are reacting to the reality.
This is a synthesized
version that gives you
great exposure to the genre.
But this is happening every day.
Right now, people are listening,
they'll never be
casted on the show 'cause
there's still that
gatekeeper aspect and
things of that nature.
And that is the
most powerful thing,
because as we
continue to bring awareness to
what's actually going on, it
inspires those that may not go
through this funnel,
that might just might make a
great product, and
put it on the App Store.
And that's a big deal.
- [Ben] I think it's been
the age of the grinder,
now it's the age of the hustler.
- And how do you define
the difference between a
grinder and a hustler?
- [Ben] A hustler works
just as hard as a grinder,
but they know that
the no is irresistible and
they're gonna come out on top.
They're not gonna work
the half-yes into the no,
they're gonna take
that no and make it a yes.
And the hustler also
is living in this age of,
maybe I'm gonna skip my
education the old-fashioned way,
maybe I'm not gonna
build a retail outlet.
Maybe I'm not gonna
spend my money on marketing.
Maybe I'm gonna use a
different kind of currency,
maybe I'm gonna bet on myself.
Maybe I'm gonna go to the
bank and get a line of credit.
Maybe I'm not gonna
enter this system, this door.
And I think it's these
people are growing up and
using their whole
street-smart skill along with
their intellect and idea,
and it's really
different, you feel it.
- [Gary] Oh,
it's super different.
Howard, biggest surprise
from what you thought was
gonna go down, to
what's manifested.
- You know, one of
the surprises really,
and I shouldn't say it was a
surprise because we wanted it
to happen, but until it
happens you don't see it is
you, Jessica,
Gwyneth, and Will becoming so
personally invested in the
apps and the creators,
and seeing you guys go
to town, and seeing you get
on planes and
meet these people and
seeing you really,
you know, care.
And I think
that we thought that,
we cast you guys,
we think you're awesome,
but you're
incredibly busy running empires,
you have a lot of
other things on your plate,
but you guys dug deep.
I was impressed by the ability
for you and your co-partners,
your advisors to stay
emotionally and mentally
connected to the process,
which was hard.
When we did this, we shot
over 10, 13 days and we did
15 hour days, and you guys
saw I think, over 100 apps.
It's a big process.
You put a lot into that.
There's a lot of
information coming at you,
and so your perseverance
and your guys' ability to
really help lift this
experience has been awesome.
- [Gary] Ben?
- You know, I'm still in it.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It's really early.
- For me, the moment as the
culture starts to expand and
absorb it, I'm thrilled
that we're starting our
consumer facing marketing
campaign and lighting it up.
- [Gary] It's a
different play, right?
With Apple than a
network, which is gonna do
everything up front
and Apple kind of
doing it along the way.
Has that been
intriguing for you?
I mean, you used
to run NBC, like,
how are you feeling about that?
- I'm totally into it, because
it is new and exciting for
me and watching it play out
and knowing where it hits the
consumer, and knowing
when the consumer finds it and
whether it's somebody kind
of entering these new doors.
Whether it's on the .com through
the Apple Music platform,
or on Apple Music itself,
or on the Apple TV platform,
all of these different
touch points inside iTunes and
then through to
Apple Music is really cool.
And the global, we
haven't yet pointed our
megaphone globally,
Apple has turned on its
platform globally, but
we haven't yet gone into
the rest of the world,
which we're gonna start to do.
And that is gonna
be really cool, too.
As we watch and find how much
the Ukranians love GaryVee.
- [Gary] Well, of course.
- Of course they do.
- [Gary] I mean,
I was born in Belarus.
Like, let's just
call it what it is.
- Come on,
those are your people.
- And Ben, you
mentioned something to me,
which I think is totally true.
And we may have
said this to you Gary,
but one of the
things that we didn't know,
we wanted the
escalator pitch to work and
be a great experience,
and we had tested it out and
looked at it, but what we
couldn't bank on was all the
entrepreneurs and
all the app creators,
are video creators in general.
Talk about the
hustler or the grinder,
these people,
whether from 17-70,
everyone by creating their
app understands visuals and
everyone understands
the creation.
- [Ben] Everyone saw a
companion up on that screen,
who's watched the
show, and thought,
"Oh, I get it.
That's a great idea.".
And then I have my
Aunt Amy who's an architect,
sending me her tweaks
on companion and how to
use it with old people
and the way she wanted to
target market it, and then--
- [Gary] Are you
calling your Aunt Amy old?
- [Ben] My Aunt Amy is old.
- [Gary] Respect.
- [Ben] But she
started old, just to be clear.
- [Gary] (laughs) Old soul?
- I think one of the
things that surprised us,
the escalator
pitch defined, for me,
it's like the age
of the storyteller.
Anyone coming down
in 60 seconds can tell a
wrenching story,
something really important,
because they live it and
they're used to selling it.
That's how they train.
- [Ben] The apps
themselves are manifested in
the screen-enabled world.
And that segway, in the
moment in the show when you
throw from what
they're doing on their iPad or
on their phone, to the
actual screen in the studio,
was like an "Aha, this
is a new Lexicon of art.".
- [Gary] Howard,
without using names,
obviously Will was very
involved very, very early,
he was locked in
as one of the mentors.
Without naming names,
you got three other mentors,
how many names were
considered for
those three spots,
and how did you guys do
with your priority list?
I'm sure you know, you went
through a lot of names before
you got down to me, so I get
that part, but the other two.
- [Howard] It's a short list,
I have to tell you.
- What was the list?
I mean, we're trying
to get some scoops here on
the GaryVee Audio Experience.
- [Both] We got
our first choices.
- Period?
- [Howard] Yeah.
- [Ben] Period.
- [Howard] Jess held
out the longest.
- [Ben] We didn't say,
"Let's go get somebody like
"Gwyneth Paltrow",
and then go get
somebody just like, tangential.
We didn't go like
Jessica Alba, we were like--
- You guys are
rolling into this studio,
and disrespecting
me in the face,
and telling me the four names...
I mean, there's no
way I was the first.
- [Ben] Listen to me,
you helped--
- The first time
I met you, you said,
"Hello, Greg Vanderput.".
Like, let's call it real here.
- GaryVee, you came
with a tornado of
enthusiasm supporting you,
not just from you.
And the moment
your name surfaced,
the army turned on its
megaphone, and that
army is also of all the
incredible friends
and entrepreneurs that
you've supported or worked
with, or people given advice to.
And it just started like
machine gun fire, honest.
And Jimmy Iovine, our kind of
mentor and godfather here in
the Apple Music Studio--
- [Gary] Made it happen.
- Built this, it's incredible.
He really connected
to you immediately.
- [Howard] You
sold him in about 30,
20 seconds, c'mon.
- 10 seconds.
- [Gary] 'Cause
he's a fucking genius!
- Yeah, Staten Island
knows it's brotherhood.
- That he is.
- [Ben] And truthfully,
Ling and Howard,
were so--
- Went to bat, absolutely.
- [Ben] And
all I was thinking,--
- [Howard] I'd try to be
in business with you
when I was at Nat Geo.
- I'm very aware.
- [Howard] I tried to reach out to you.
- Yes, you deserve the credit.
- [Ben] And I was
just thinking, I'm like,
he wants to bank the show,
he wants to finance it.
He doesn't wanna,
'cause initially--
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Ben] You wanted to be--
- I wanted to
be the singular VC.
- [Ben] Yeah, you wanted
to be the VC and the ment,
so it was a whole--
- I wanted to be the mentor,
the people pitching, and the VC.
- [Howard] Exactly.
- I think it should have
been Planet of GaryVee.
Let's call it what it
really should have been.
- [Ben] And that may end up.
- Now let's talk
about some inside scoops.
First day of filming was
November 14th, my birthday.
I refused to not be with
my family, so I missed it.
You guys did some run-throughs.
Howard, I think you sat
in for me and acted as me.
- [Howard] It's true.
- It was a disaster.
(Howard laughing)
I come the next day--
- [Howard] We were all panicked.
- It's the greatest of all time.
Do we then give me the credit
for being the glue of this show?
- [Ben] I think we
more than confirmed
Howard's ineptitude
at being on the show.
(group laughter)
But while you may have
salvaged sand in the desert--
- Yes.
- [Ben] We felt very good
that that show was gonna crush
and albeit you are
a star among stars,
when you turn
on that screen in the 4K
and are watching at
home all chilled out
in any manifestation you want
and you see the four
of you up on that screen,
you're not seeing
four people like you
that accomplished,
that focused, that articulate,
and half of them that beautiful.
- Yeah, I mean,
Will is gorgeous.
- [Ben] Stunning.
- [Howard] And the other,
the thing is,
you have four
different personalities
and bring something different--
- Absolutely.
- [Howard] from
a TV perspective.
- [Ben] Totally.
- [Howard] But
also then what we saw
which is fascinating,
you all have business,
different business--
- [Gary] Filters.
- Filters.
- Yeah.
- And different
ways that you conduct,
and different
ways that you think,
and that added
another wrinkle to it,
that we really hadn't
anticipated which is awesome.
- [Gary] Do you guys get
excited as I do that forever,
forever you will be
associated with producing
Apple Music's
first original show.
I mean whatever happens
if there's a season two,
if there's 30 seasons,
it's just always
there and I think it speaks
to knowing your
guys' career a little bit,
it's that innovation arm, right?
Fashion stars, I mean look,
I didn't know
until you brought it up
one day in the trailer,
I didn't know that was you guys.
I didn't know the
Hollywood landscape.
To me, that was just very smart
and for me that's like credit.
I think in a lot of
ways this new distribution
obviously Netflix
and other OTTs exist.
But let's call it what it is,
this is the most
powerful company in the world
at this moment.
This is their first foray
into something that
you guys grew up in.
To me a lot of this
has happened backwards,
entrepreneurship and
it's backed into culture.
This is what you guys dreamed
and aspire to
do your whole life.
It must be pretty fantastic.
- We're psyched.
- It's amazing
and I would just say
that one of the things
that has been really,
one of the things that has been
such a great gift is that Apple
has really supported
creativity from the beginning.
We pitched them the show,
they liked the idea,
and they really
allowed us to make it.
And they've really kind of,
it's no surprise that
great things happen here
and that they've
been responsible
for some of the
most innovative--
- [Gary] Things.
- Things, launches ever.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And they
support creative thinking
and that's something--
- Well design,
design is such a core element
to the culture of the company
and so we're
all kind of designers
in this convergent world
whether we're
tech entrepreneurs,
video makers,
platform builders.
There's an element
of design and aesthetic
that permeates
everything we're all doing,
especially as it relates
to the consumer.
- [Gary] Let's wrap up with this
because there's a
lot of people listening,
I know my audience.
What's happening in Hollywood?
It's changing, right?
The game's changing.
We're talking
about OTT, influencers.
How things get funded.
It's never been
better to be a great creator
because you do have
Hulu, Apple Music, Amazon
to go along with
HBO and Showtime,
to go along with the networks.
Facebook is gonna
have its original port
like what is
happening in this town
from some real vets, right?
Forget about Apple,
forget about the
battalion and the light speed,
in the GaryVee tech filter.
What's the
Hollywood inside talk?
Do people realize it's changing?
Do they think it's good?
Do they think it's bad?
What's the
punch line in this town?
- [Ben] I think there's a
combo effect going on
and there's
definitely a generational shift
and those who love culture
creation and storytelling
are pretty content
because they're
getting their stories told
and the content created.
Those who just care about bucks
are a little nervous because
the dollar is getting squeezed
by all these giant
vertically integrated companies
and this massive oligopoly
that controls voice in America,
real and fake voice in America,
is a little intimidating for
the storytelling community
because it's hard to
get your stories sustained
in that environment.
And it's a little
scary on the business side
and that's
something that you feel
like this
combination of excitement
from those who are here
about the pure creativity
and nervousness from those have
been in the game a long time
and are watching things
go from 22 episodes to 10.
From owning back ends,
take in open markets,
to owning back ends
and profit participations
going into closed markets.
There's a lot of stuff that is
nerve-wracking in that sense.
- [Gary] Howard?
- And one of the things you
guys were talking about earlier
is in the VC world
like coin is the new thing
that coin is the new--
- Vernacular.
- In our vernacular,
what storytellers
like Ben and I are saying
is that video
is the new currency
and in that we live
in a video-enabled world.
My kids don't,
yes they probably text and stuff
but they live on
YouTube and on Instagram
and it's a visual
video-enabled world
and I think as that grows
the opportunity for storytellers
just expands.
- [Gary] Expands.
- Expands and magnifies.
- [Gary] 100%.
- And we're just bullish on--
- AR, VR.
Also where you
get to tell the story.
- Tuesday nights,
9:00 ET, right?
9:00 P.M., Eastern.
- [Ben] 9:00 P.M. Pacific,
midnight Eastern.
- Oh, is that right?
- [Howard] It's such a
great launching pad, right?
- That is not true.
No no, Ben I think that
was the first episode, yeah.
- [Ben] We're back.
- We're back.
You scared the fuck out of me.
- [Ben] I scared myself.
- 9:00 P.M. ET, I scared myself.
As it came out of
your lips you were like,
why the fuck are we launching
at midnight on the East Coast?
- [Ben] Yeah.
- East Coast is the epicenter.
Guys, New York is the
epicenter of the world.
L.A.'s an afterthought.
- [Ben] Ratings-wise.
- Life-wise.
- [Ben] But it's good
that you've
discounted the rest of the world
who also will get it
at varying time periods.
- I'm an Ameri,
listen, I might have
been born in the Soviet Union
but I'm an American.
Americans don't even
realize Canada or Mexico,
I mean Americans
are terrible at this.
- [Ben] As the man has
been a Ghana and Romania,
the past ten days.
- Yes.
- [Ben] You do travel, Gary.
- Yes, but I'm trying
to speak for the people.
(group laughter)
- [Howard] GaryVee,
DRock, Tyler--
- Guys, thank you, thank you.
- [Howard] You guys rock.
- Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the opportunity.
- [Howard] Over and out.
- [Ben] You're the best, GaryVee.
- See ya.
- [Gary] Hey guys, I hope
you really enjoyed
this episode of
The GaryVee Experience.
Now go out and
share this, pass it on.
Let me know what you thought.